happy new year now come on let's be
honest isn't this the time to finally
stick to that new year's resolution to
cook more well come on i have all the
perfect recipes and tips and tricks for
you all welcome to ramsey in 10.
[Music]
right babette or flank whatever you like
to call it this steak trust me it's so
versatile and really delicious
especially for those on the go like me
it's so quick to cook with and i'm going
to show you how to make a blackened
steak with a delicious kimchi fried rice
adding some beautiful korean flair to
your standard steak right come on oscar
pan down let me show you the ingredients
so this is it
this is a beautiful flank steak and it's
a bit of a chef's cut but more
importantly the flavor is incredible
okay so it looks slightly ugly it's not
your fillet not your rib eye but it is
so delicious cheap and cheerful and
freaking delicious leftover rice
from the weekend
okay a little bit of chili saturating
the oil some beautiful radish to finish
to give that nice acidity some kimchi
buffered eggs a little bit of um spring
onions or scallions across the pond
and then these um in order to cook a
steak properly you need a decent pan so
these are the rolls-royce of pans right
first off
let's get 10 minutes on the clock
right first things first always take
this steak out of the fridge okay don't
cook the steak ice cold okay so take out
the fish ten minutes before you start
cooking it that makes it relax it starts
to render the fat and
more importantly
it cooks so much quicker at room
temperature bit of salt bit of pepper
okay so i like that to sort of sit there
okay
and sort of almost marinate now pans on
get them really nice and hot okay the
actual kimchi fried rice i want to get
some texture on there as well and then
we're going to top that off with a fried
egg so cook your fried egg
nice and slowly i like to start off and
then let it sit and rest
but
let's get some power into that steak a
couple of tablespoons of soy sauce okay
a couple of tablespoons of hoisin sauce
okay oops mmm delicious
a couple teaspoons of hoisin sauce
literally equal measures from there
mix that up
okay and then just lightly brush that
steak
okay
brush now you want to cover that
now as you can see i've got
all that sort of marinade there
again
over roll that in
and again generously okay there's a
really nice fat marbling running through
this steak the secret behind this cut of
steak you've got to let it rest you
never slice this piping hot okay the
minute you slice it piping hot you're
gonna burst the steak and you're gonna
lose all that amazing flavor
now
i've already got the marinade in there
okay so we don't need to all the pan
i've got the marinade on my plate
now that i've seasoned it
just a touch more
each side
if you want to impart some really good
flavor get that done the night before
wait to see the difference in flavor is
extraordinary
in
and lay away from me in the pan okay six
o'clock
right through to
12 o'clock right on top
now
time please
two minutes gone
okay touch of olive oil in there give
that a nice little shake
now for the rice
get that pan super hot
okay if your pans are getting too hot
too quickly just slide it turn it down
slide it off the heat it's a quick way
of cooling down a pan
now from there
we've got a really nice color
you want to caramelize that okay
kimchi
hot pan
tablespoon of oil and then drain off
some of that vinegar
okay
and just get it in between the cloth and
pat it nice and dry that's going to get
that kimchi nice and crispy
into the pan
beautiful
really beautiful touch of salt
now look at my steak
coloring beautifully up
and over
again almost got that sort of nice light
barbecue
flavor oscar panda and panda and some
pan down look look at that flavor in
there caramelizing fats rendering down
and got that nice intense heat
right kimchi
now we've got some color on there
out the kimchi okay
touch more olive oil and then open up
your rice when i say open up i mean sort
of just sort of sprinkle it in there
and as you're running out through your
fingers like that you're opening up
those little
rice grains
and that way it's going to get really
nice and crispy
do not touch it okay just leave it there
and get it nice and crispy it's like a
sort of snack crackle and pop
time please
six minutes
four minutes gone thank you
right
look at that steak
best thing to do now turn off the gas
okay
let that cool down and look get your
marinade and just brush that over there
again
that's right i'm gonna leave the steak
cooling down in the pan okay
turn that over
and literally
brush
beautiful
let that sit there and almost cool down
in this marinade
so beautiful now the rice let me show
you a little trick
get the ladle
and just
bang it down
you get that rice really nice and crispy
okay push push push push down
you'll see why in a minute from there a
little touch of salt
a little touch of pepper
and
just a
hint
of chili flake okay
now for my egg okay
start off a little bit of olive oil
take off the heat
lightly
crack the eggs on a flat surface
and then again look at the color of
these yolks
beautiful
a touch of salt
a touch of pepper bring up the heat and
let it cook nice and slowly
so look in
pan down pan down please look at these
eggs look at these eggs look at the
color those yolks come on
that is beautiful
now from there keep that rice super flat
time please
30 seconds
right again slow let's go
now
this is where the rice
sort of almost takes on a different
level a lot i want to get it there and
just start flipping that look at that
come down down pan down pull down that
is what i call kimchi fried rice that is
so beautiful okay again pat it back down
nice and flat
okay and get it crispy again
right
some
spring onions
scallions spring onions
whatever takes your fancy
bob's your uncle
and fami's your grandma
now slice those
sprinkles down
beautifully done
into the pan
don't turn them over
eggs coming up
look at that egg beautiful really
beautiful
now look at that rice
again flip that over and look
that is crispy
back down and you turn that around time
please
three minutes to go now keep that rice
nice and flat
every time we flatten it it gets really
nice and crispy
now egg
just get that little butter on the side
and you'll see that frotting up and
literally
getting that nice
yolk beautifully cooked
from there
keep that rice nice and flat
really important
and then as that butter starts to froth
it cooks the top of the egg okay really
nice way of finishing it now for the
acidity
the secret here is to take a grater
and get these nice little radishes
and just sort of lightly grate and all
we're doing here is just put a little
bit of acidity
onto the dish
watch your fingers
grate nicely
i'll use a little touch of the juice of
the kimchi
okay just in
a little bit of lemon
okay
and then just literally
let that sit
and mix now in there
a touch of salt
a little touch of chili flake
time please
two minutes to go
now for the magic
to plate this thing look at that rice
okay
the rice
this is a very generous and a very sort
of uh
you know
it's a bit of a chef's dish okay because
it's just packed with flavor
that kimchi rice is just
delicious it's crispy
it's spicy it's everything you want from
rice
take my eggs off
turn off the gas
and now
look
with this beautiful steak don't you dare
go too thin just open
and
slice sit that on
i want those juices from my pan over the
steak all the flavors in there and then
bang
get my eggs
and that literally just sits
on top and underneath there is that
surprise and then look
with my radish
the pickling goes there
i've got this nice beautiful
little scallop underneath
time please
and there you go a beautiful cream flare
fried kimchi rice with the most amazing
steak and eggs in under 10 minutes
[ __ ] i'm getting good
you're unbelievable
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsey and
ten cookbook inspired by this series and
trust me you're gonna come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck